les suppressions de postes de juges
d'instruction prennent en compte les
résultats électoraux du parti la
république en marche
il s'agirait de protéger les territoires
qu'ils votent bien et punir et lâche qui
vont très mal il s'agit là d'un nouveau
scandale d'état d'une dérive grave
relevant de la politique politicienne
en effet après le mur des cons élaboré
par un syndicat de magistrats
voilà maintenant un mur des comptes
directement élaboré par les services du
ministère de la justice en fonction du
vote de nos concitoyens en faveur ou en
défaveur de monsieur maquereau ou de son
parti l'intrusion de considérations
politiciennes dans l'ordre du judiciaire
est un manquement grave à la stricte
séparation des pouvoirs et aux
fondements de la démocratie
tous les services de l'état doivent
naturellement agir dans l'impartialité
la semaine dernière à mantes la jolie
une centaine d'individus a attaqué trois
fonctionnaires de police avec une
extrême violence des faits similaires se
sont produits dans d'autres villes des
yvelines comme dans l'ensemble du pays
ces actes inacceptables sont d'une
grande lâcheté et inspire le dégoût à
tous et plus particulièrement à ceux qui
habitent le quartier où se sont produits
les faits qui m'ont dit leur
incompréhension du laxisme qui prévaut
face aux coupables de ces actes et
réclame des réactions exemplaires
ces actes criminels doivent cesser leurs
auteurs doivent être punis avant il y
avait le respect de l'autorité
maintenant on va provoquer lille
autoriser l'autorité c'est inacceptable
monsieur le premier ministre que comptez
vous faire pour rétablir l'ordre
républicain la philosophe sylviane
agacinsky a été empêchée de prononcer
une conférence à l'université de
bordeaux
plusieurs associations avaient en effet
menacé de s'y opposer par la force au
prétexte que madame agacinsky a pris
position contre la gestation pour autrui
par crainte des violences l'université
de bordeaux a annulé la conférence
monsieur le premier ministre cet épisode
est proprement scandaleux
mais le scandale il est aussi dans le
silence assourdissant de votre
gouvernement ni la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur ni le ministre
de l'éducation nationale d'habitude si
prolixe non dénoncer cette atteinte
insupportable à la liberté de penser à
la liberté d'expression et aux libertés
universitaires
vous travaillez depuis deux ans monsieur
le ministre à une réforme des retraites
et la semaine dernière encore vous avez
été désavoué par le président de la
république
quant au modèle que vous proposiez vous
aviez annoncé un aboutissement de la
réforme avant les municipales puis après
les municipales ce qui est plus sage
puis maintenant ça semble repoussée aux
calendes grecques
vous nous avez proposé de passer d'un
système de répartition à un système de
points
vous avez annoncé la fin des régimes
spéciaux mais on apprend par la presse
que ça tangue au sein du gouvernement
vous avez dit vous même que l'option
d'une réforme de régimes spéciaux pour
les nouveaux entrants n'était pas votre
tasse de thé elle était celle du
président en vérité une seule chose
semble sûre c'est que vous avez fait le
choix de la baisse du pouvoir d'achat
des retraités puisque les pensions ne
seront pas rêver la risée en 2020 alors
monsieur le ministre croit que le temps
le temps est venu de tomber les masques
de regarder les français dans les yeux
de leur dire la vérité sans en même
temps permanent quels sont aujourd'hui
les bases de travail car et vous en tête
où voulez vous emmener les français sur
ces questions de retraite plus de
calendrier caducité des propositions
initiales cacophonie dans les annonces
on n'y comprend plus rien le 80 km heure
n'a pas permis de sauver plus de vies
cette mesure est un échec
vous l'avez tellement bien compris que
vous renvoyez maintenant au président
département la responsabilité d'une
décision non concertée qu'ils n'ont
jamais souhaité il vous savez pourtant
mis en garde ceux qui veulent passer aux
90 km heure sont freinés par des
conditions drastiques élaboré par des
instruisent ou experts du comité
national de sécurité routière qui à mon
sens ne doivent jamais été passés de peu
d'effets eric
[Musique]